bonjour à tous je suis très heureux de
vous inviter à l'université de rentrée
du MoDem qui se déroulera le 29 37
septembre et 1er octobre donc dès
aujourd'hui inscrivez-vous mobilisez
autour de vous aussi bien nos adhérents
nos militants que des amis des
compagnons de route ont envie de venir
débattre avec nous on vient jamais à
Guidel par hasard et cette année c'est
une année de congrès au début de l'année
prochaine il y aura notre congrès du
Mouvement Démocrate et donc c'est le
moment de commencer à réfléchir ensemble
et puis je crois que il y a une deuxième
raison qui est très importante c'est que
les Français ont besoin de ressentir on
est en phase avec eux on entend leurs
attentes et que nous allons poser
ensemble des constats des perspectives
et la vision dont le pays a besoin
à très vite
[Musique]